Is the pre cosmo Garnett chaos.
This is from
William James,
who was a pragmatist,
lived on each coast at about
the end of the 18 hundreds.
He was one of the founders
of modern psychology.
He liked to sniff nitric nitrous oxide,
which is a hallucinogen.
He was sort of like the world's first
major league hippie and he wrote sort of
hippie poetry as a consequence of
his nitrous oxide experimentation.
And here's part of what a he
derived from his experiences.
So,
um,
pure experience is the name which I
give to the original flux of life before
reflection is categorized,
it only newborn babes and
persons in semi coma from sleep,
drugs,
illnesses or blows.
It can have an experience pure in the
literal sense of awe that which is not yet
any definite what potential
potential cause you might think,
well what's the world made of?
It's made out of actuality,
right?
That's not how you act.
You Act as if the world's made out of
potential and you interact with that
potential.
And what James is saying is that there
are times when you experience something
that's akin to relatively pure potential.
And then you might ask yourself
whether or not potential is real,
which is a really interesting question,
but I can say regardless of
how you answered that question,
you act as if it's real and you'll also
feel guilty if someone that you love
comes up to you and says,
you're not living up to your potential.
It's like,
what the hell does that mean?
What does it mean?
It means you're not becoming
that which you could be.
Well,
what is that?
It's like,
you know,
we're materialists.
How are we going to measure that?
You can't touch it.
You can't taste it.
You can't see it.
You can't measure it.
Right?
But,
but nonetheless,
it's like the substance of being and
being his potential as well as actuality.
And we're grappling
always with the potential.
And so that's what James is talking about.
Pure potential.
I like to think of it as
latent information full
both of oneness and menace,
but in respects that don't
appear changing throughout yet.
So confusedly that it's phases.
Interpenetrate sounds like the Yin and
Yang symbol and no points either of
distinction or of identity can be caught.
Here's his poem.
No verbiage can give it because
the verbiage is other incoherent,
coherent the same and it fades and
it's infinite and it's infinite.
Don't you see the difference?
Don't you see the identity constantly?
Opposites United the same.
Me telling you to write and not to right.
Extreme,
extreme,
extreme something.
And other than that thing,
intoxication and otherness
than intoxication.
Every attempted betterment.
Every attempted other men is a,
it fades and it fades forever
and forever as we move.